hum
bom dia a todos é um alegria para mim
estar aqui vocês podem estar se
perguntando o que gratidão tem que ver
com os sons da nossa vida e espero que
no final vocês descubram que a gratidão
é um desses sentimentos que podem se
expressar de várias maneiras desde o
estardalhaço o exagero na apresentação
do sentimento até no silêncio que às
vezes é o melhor de todos os sons
eu gosto de falar de gratidão porque ela
é a mais nova das virtudes e sem dúvida
ela é uma marca implacável no caráter
das pessoas
como é muito improvável que alguém passe
pela vida sem ter que em algum momento
alguém lhe tenha estendido a mão
nós podemos dizer com certeza sem
nenhuma margem de erro que o malága
decido não presta e não é possível ser
generoso com esse tipo de gente
o nosso primeiro sentimento de gratidão
e deve estar lá na infância o nosso pai
que travestido de herói pequenos ocorreu
numa situação de temor e nós o amamos
naquele momento mais do que em qualquer
outra situação ou a nossa mãe que varou
a noite sem sono e sem fome para vigiar
uma febre vizinha vagabundo
uma coisa interessante é que esse
sentimento pelos pais frequentemente só
é percebido quando nós temos filhos
quando meu filho tinha um ano e meio ele
teve uma crise convulsiva
isso coincidiu com um surto de meningite
em porto alegre
e eu lembro do pânico na família até
provar que aquela crise era uma crise
como se você abriu sem nenhuma relação
com epilepsia que era o grande fantasma
ou com meningite
o problema é que depois daquilo cada vez
que ele tinha febre no nosso carro
sobressaltados com receio de outra
solução
eu lembro de uma noite em que ele estava
com febre eu tentei
várias maneiras baixar a febre não
conseguia parece que pai consegue -
quando o paciente é filho e não
conseguia baixar a febre eu passei a
noite vigiando quando estava amanhecendo
o dia eu me dei conta que o jeito que eu
amava meu filho era muito e uma chave
tão bonita depois ele piorou mas ele era
realmente muito bonito
o jeito que eu amava meu filho não devia
ser original não havia nenhuma razão
para eu ter uma forma nova de amar e que
meu pai devia ter-me a mata
da mesma maneira e eu lembro da surpresa
e do susto que provocou no meu pai
quando ele fez uma declaração de amor
inesperado às seis da manhã e ele que
sabe naturalmente o que estava muito
errado
depois nós vamos nos lembrar com certeza
do nosso colega que nos ocorreu numa
briga de adolescentes ou da primeira
namorada que fez de conta que não
percebi o quanto nós dançávamos mal no
bairro do clube
e mais adiante é provável que nos
lembremos e eu me lembro da professora
de português que disse para toda a
classe que aquela redação devia servir
de modelo para os outros e eu me sentir
como um gênio da literatura finalmente
reconhecido
será uma maravilha
se a nossa actividade profissional se
ela for capaz de modificar a vida das
pessoas porque essa é a vida que vale a
pena a vida que é capaz de modificar a
qualidade da vida dos outros
eu estou convencido que nós podemos
contabilizar a qualidade de uma vida
pelo número de vezes que nós suscitamos
em outras pessoas o sentimento de
gratidão
quem trabalha com um médico e um médico
é uma pessoa que convive com as empresas
e os temores minhas fantasias da morte
ele acaba viciado em gratidão é fácil
entender nessa nossa atividade está
sempre margeando o sofrimento e
desespero e nós definitivamente nunca
esquecemos das pessoas que foram
solidários com o nosso sofrimento
da mesma maneira
e é um instrumento de aversão
poderosíssimo a desconsideração do
sofrimento
nós podemos esquecer um favor mas jamais
esqueceremos uma uma desconsideração da
atividade médica nós aprendemos que as
pessoas mais simples as pessoas mais
toscas elas têm muito mais facilidade de
expressar gratidão porque elas nunca
exercitaram a hipocrisia do convívio
social
elas nunca tiveram que aparentar ser ele
o que não era e sendo o que sempre foram
elas conseguem ser mais espontâneas e
mais e mais generosa
eu lembro de uma tarde chegou no
hospital à maria emília maria minella
maneira de uns 40 anos uma cara bonita
tinha sofrido um atropelamento foi
atropelado por uma bicicleta e quebrou
uma costela e eu lembro que quando eu
sentei com ela eo marido que era um
neuro uma cara muitas não têm buscado
muito desconfiado e eu é para amenizar o
encontro disse nós no futuro ainda íamos
falar daquele atropelamento como um
atropelamento abençoado porque ele
permitirá descobrir um nódulo de um
pulmão que era um câncer de dois
cêntimos do qual ela deveria curar pela
sorte que tiveram de ser atropelado ele
achou muito estranho essa associação
mas o certo é que funcionou ela foi
operada curou e nós ficamos muito muito
amigos
ele era dono de uma tenda de frutas
dessas beira da calçada e fizeram várias
consultas comigo nos anos que se
seguiram nunca foram a uma consulta sem
levar alguma coisa de presente
nem que fosse uma maçã uma pêra uma vez
ganha uma banana com todo simbolismo de
ganhar uma banana do paciente mas mas
era a expressão de gratidão possível
naquele momento e muitas vezes eu
comprei frutas as vendas compras frutas
vencidas na tentativa de ajudá los
porque a condição econômica deles era
ruim no ano passado
quinze anos depois eu paro na calçada do
lado da tenda de lhe pergunta como estão
as coisas e ele me disse adutor muito
mal muito mal porque parece que as
pessoas estão convencidas que só se deve
comprar frutas no supermercado só
precisa ter uma idéia eu não to
conseguindo comprar antibiótico
para negra velha que está muito enganado
ele deu uma nota de 50 reais para ele
comprar o antibiótico sinal abriu foi
embora
um mês depois voltou de novo parado na
esquina e ele corre lá e disse doutor
aquele dia o senhor saiu apressado nem
pude agradecer ao senhor é uma pessoa
boa não quero passar por mal agradecida
então eu queria dizer uma coisa é a
minha especialidade está mais para o
lado da bandidagem de modo que se tiver
alguém me incomodando o senhor só medida
quem é que um susto a gente garante o
senhor só tem que me dizer o tamanho do
susto
eu fiquei muito assustado porque eu não
eu não tenho idéia de como é que
classifica a susto
como é um susto média um susto grande
eu contei essa história da minha coluna
zero hora e terminei dizendo que ficamos
combinados que era pra dar um recado aos
meus potenciais desafetos
eu não sou um pobre médico desprotegido
tenho lá minha retaguarda
certo é que funcionou a gratidão ela ela
pode algumas vezes exagerada ser
cuidadosa mas eu aprendi que a
verdadeira gratidão não precisa de de
tambores um pediatra amigo meu me contou
que recebeu uma criança em parada
cardíaca em uma grande emergência do
hospital público e iniciadas manobras de
ressuscitação uma situação extremamente
tensa porque é um 11 numa fronteira
muito estreita com a morte
ele percebeu que enquanto eles tomavam
as medidas de ressuscitação uma senhora
assistia à cena encostada numa numa
coluna depois de uma hora e meia de
tentativa frustrada de voltar e fazer
aquele coraçãozinho voltar a bater a
criança foi considerada tecnicamente
morta e cada um voltou às atividades no
fim do dia ele saiu pelos fundos do
hospital e percebeu que no meio do pátio
que havia aquela senhora estava sentado
no banco de pedra chorando ele teve
certeza que aquela mulher era a mãe da
criança morta
ele se aproximou abraçou pelos pelos
homens e caminharam juntos
é importante saída quando ela lhe tomam
de jô eles começem jeito de beija-mão de
volta e ele foi para a esquerda em
direção ao estacionamento e ela foi para
a direita para o ponto de ônibus
nenhuma palavra mas é provável que nunca
tenha havido um silêncio mais eloqüente
existem situações em que não há
necessidade de palavras
é muito importante perceber que a
gratidão tem várias formas de
apresentação e às vezes ela tem algum
requinte que permite que ela seja
lembrada de maneira definitiva e curiosa
aconteceu isso com eduardo eduardo eram
um bancário de 49 anos da bahia é que
tinha fibrose pulmonar e veio pra cá
para transplantar o pulmão e toda a
preocupação do eduardo antes do
transplante
não é só com o fogo ele queria saber o
quanto com fôlego novo à sua atividade
sexual voltaria ao normal
ele disse que sim que nós nunca teríamos
um atleta sexual com falta de ar que ele
ia ficar bem mas ele várias vezes
assistia com esse meu irmão me diga de
novo como é que é volta não volta na
mini garanta ea preocupação dele é essa
ele foi transplantado dois meses e meio
depois que ele foi embora toca o
telefone na minha casa no meio da
madrugada
eu levei aquele sobressalto de quem está
habituado ao fato de que telefone no
meio da madrugada significa que você vai
ter que sair porque tem algum problema
cirurgia e quando eu atendi aquele
sotaque inconfundível né
amar é eduardo consegui e eu voltei a
dormir muito feliz porque eu tinha de
alguma maneira participado dessa peça
orgias virtual né
e eu tinha na verdade aprendido com
eduardo um modelo novo de gratidão ea
gratidão com urgência porque ele não foi
capaz de esperar que amanhecesse para me
telefonar
ele ainda estava ofegante da sua proeza
mas ele precisava compartilhar com quem
ele achava que tinha uma parte
importante nisso
claro que a gente fica contente com
qualquer expressão de gratidão mas eu
sempre me encantei com as pessoas
capazes de serem graças não quando as
coisas deram certo e isso parece quase
obrigatório mas quando as coisas deram
muito erradas eu transfronteira uns anos
atrás um homem de 58 anos de gravataí o
joão batista é um doce de pessoa
ele sofria muito de falta de água ele
foi transplantado tem uma evolução
inicial maravilhosa foi embora
três semanas depois da alta e voltou pro
hospital muito mal com febre e falta de
ar e uma combinação terrível assim uma
rejeição aguda poderosa e uma infecção
por fungo que é uma associação
praticamente sempre mortal tanto que ele
morreu dois dias depois
mais de dois meses mais tarde eu recebia
uma filha querida dele que tinha uma
missão delegada pelo pai a caminho do
hospital
lá durante o início da complicação e o
pedido dela era que o pai morrer disse
ao chegar no hospital e será minha filha
eu acho que vou morrer porque eu nunca
me senti tão mal
eu queria que acontecer aconteça o que
acontecer não deixa de agradecer ao
doutor e diga a ele que eu faria tudo
outra vez por aquelas três semanas que
eu respirei feito gente infelizmente
esse tipo de gente é raro eu aprendi que
nada aproxima mais o médico do paciente
do que o paciente é tratado com um igual
dade e isso é uma coisa que assemelha ao
médico e o professor essa sincronia de
afectos e sentimentos o que faz com que
o médico eo professor sejam figuras que
figuram quase sempre no imaginário das
pessoas com espaço para a idolatria é
comum sobre a entrevista de pessoas
famosas que vão
está lá a professora da primeira
infância e o médico que salvou de uma
situação provavelmente vantajosa
imaginária e do qual ele não é nunca
esqueceu
eu aprendi que tratar o paciente com
como um ser igual revelando até quando
necessário a fragilidade do médico é a
coisa que mais nos aproximará eu recebi
no hospital há uns anos atrás
uma criança de 10 anos que tinha caído
de uma construção e foi internada em
coma profundo durante as primeiras 36
horas ela fez três cirurgias e rompido
atacante do pronto uma queda de grande
altura e no dia seguinte ela foi
submetida a uma cirurgia de abdômen para
a remoção do baço e ela nunca acordou
dez dias depois dessa demissão em que eu
tinha ficado muito impressionado com o
esforço ea proteção daquela mãe que
varavam dias e noites sem dormir sem
sono sem fome e cuidando daqueles aquela
cara linda os olhos enormes concílios
virados à aliás aquela cara linda
atormentou muitas das minhas madrugadas
depois que tudo terminou quando eu saí
da uti completamente arrasado com essa
informação
é eu encontrei a minha secretária que me
disse que nós tínhamos nove pacientes
para atender como não tinha condição de
atender ninguém eu tive um impulso e
pedir que que a luz passasse todos na
mansão
você pode imaginar o ar de surpresa ter
19 desconhecidos que entra na sala do
médico e vamos ter então a medicina deve
ter avançado muito vamos ter uma
consulta coletiva
e aí eu contei exatamente o que tinha
acontecido eu perdi uma criança um
paciente muito importante estou muito
mal e eu preciso saber se algum dos
senhores têm alguma condição de urgência
que eu possa pedir o colega que os
atenda senão eu gostaria muito que vocês
voltassem todos amanhã porque agora eu
preciso muito sair do hospital pra
chorar e aí houve uma comoção naquela
sala 101 nomes conhecidos que se
abraçaram se deram as mãos se tocaram e
no dia seguinte
eles não só voltarão todos como eles
estavam claramente fiscalizando para ver
se algum insensível pudesse não ter
percebido o drama do doutor
eles não só estavam lá todos como
durante os anos que se seguiram vários
daqueles nove pacientes fizeram
consultas desnecessárias comigo por
causa dessa história que eles achavam
que merecia ser repetida é porque isso
tinha marcado tanto a vida deles quanto
a minha
se você perguntar mas o que aconteceu de
tão especial nada nada simplesmente o
médico admitindo que como qualquer
pessoa
nós todos temos momentos na vida em que
nós não temos nada melhor para fazer do
que parar pra chorar eu aprendi que essa
identidade essa sincronia de sentimentos
e de afectos é o que mais aproxima
pessoas em qualquer circunstância alegre
feliz sofrida desesperada a identidade
de afectos e sentimentos e que torna as
pessoas realmente conectadas igualdade e
generosidade
é uma combinação que para mim representa
a mais segura fonte geradora de gratidão
pratiquem e depois depois contei pra mim
muito obrigado
e dom
é bom